look jack there goes my world there goes
my everything
just stop worrying she's just a maid
just a maid
that's like saying that pradas are just
shoes or
vodka is just a morning beverage
oh sorry i'm late oh god that sounded
insincere
i'm late karen
karen yeah stan get off of me
[Applause]
where am i karen
you are at work it's 10 30 in the
morning
and because you seem to believe that
fabric
can be sent over phone lines
i now owe this guy 150 bucks for a
service call
oh my god it's 10 30. honey why'd you
let me sleep so
late i got to get out of here
there's a needle full of botulism with
my forehead's name written all over it
i can't believe i'm at a public pool why
doesn't somebody just pee directly on me
look at all of these stan has been so
good to me honey oh and all of the sweet
memories they bring back
on my knees in belize
[Applause]
oh on my back in iraq
then there was that time in nantucket
[Applause]
good times well good jewels anyway
oh look here stands well do you have a
well honey why do i need a whale i'm
gonna live forever
that is the deal isn't it red with
everything that's been going on with me
lately
stan staying in prison me all alone in
the house with
16 servants most of whom don't even jump
anymore when i shoot at their feet
well your news really gives me something
to smile about
what are you doing i'm looking for
tissues i'll have your assistant get
them for you
she's late again oh fire her already
i'm not gonna fire karen her social
contacts keep my business afloat
why does she even work i mean isn't she
worth like a gazillion dollars
she feels working keeps her down to
earth i know
i'm late my driver had another bronchial
incident
oh that was disgusting i had to raise
the partition
but that's no excuse i should be
punished i'm writing you a check
karen tell grace she should fire you
grace tell will to redirect his anger at
his mother where it belongs
[Music]
call me later hi all right honey there
you go
guilt be gone
karen i don't want to check i want
assistance i'm the boss i give you
checks
yes you do honey and i love them i do
you know i keep them all right here in
this box
hey what what's going on what's
happening what's with the tv oh
i'm watching what i would call the
feel-good movie of my life
did you rent pretty woman again
come on give it up honey the only thing
you two have in common is horse teeth
and bad taste in men
[Laughter]
you're a filthy little piggy
[Applause]
[Laughter]
karen something you want
to tell me mr me
what's going on honey what's happening
why aren't you licking that floor
oh all right it is me but it's not what
you think really
cause i think it's you and a maid's
uniform
whipping some old guy in a onesie am i
wrong
come on it's just a little fetish film
oh my god how did this thing get into
circulation
oh my god this is the end of me
i don't think i can go on karen what are
you
doing karen don't be ridiculous there we
go nice and cold
[Applause]
oh boy just one question is dirty little
pig boy the other white meat
come on spill it well i was just out of
college i was broke it's the oldest
story in the world
boy meets girl boy wants girl to do
dominatrix film
girl says naked boy says yeah girl says
forget it boy says okay
then just wear this rubber dress and
beat the old guy with a scrub brush girl
says how hard
i find that appalling oh yeah well i
find stretch pants appalling but i'm too
much of a lady to mention it fat ass
hey honey wow i love your new bag
it's garbage oh thank god you said it
no kids ruin everything i mean look at
the stitching on this thing huh
you cannot trust a ten-year-old to do a
good hidden button
you have a very delightful chuckle oh
thank you they're real too
nano banks lionel like the train
banks like money and you are anastasia
beaverhausen
anastasia like russian royalty
beaverhausen like
where the beaver live
dynamite what brings you to this lush
paradise
miss beaver
oh i don't know really just killing time
i suppose
waiting for something good to happen
interesting i was just doing the same
thing
looks like my weight is over
well well where did you come from lionel
did the smooth talking gigolo convention
let out early
listen why don't we continue this in my
very comfortable suite upstairs i've got
loads of cash so
time is no issue
mr banks you think i'm a hooker
body in those clothes that voice yes
well as flattered as i am by that i'm
afraid i have to disappoint you
you don't have sex for money no i do not
we're jewels for furs for mixed
securities like a lady
what for money how dare you what's your
version of sex huh what gets you too
excited
the most excited
that would have to be without question
game night oh
sounds tedious you should do that
you're right we should it is so
it's so fun every year joe and larry and
rob and ellen come over
and we have this this big huge parlor
game
blowout we play for the suck on it cup
god that's tragic what's that
it's a trophy and we call it the suck on
it cup because when you win
and will and i always win you get to
turn to the losers and say
suck on
which lever do i pull to be crushed by a
safe
grace it's christmas for goodness sake
think about the baby jesus
up in that tower letting his hair down
so that the three wise men can climb up
and spin the dreidel and see if there's
six more weeks of winter
what don't try you have will's firm oh
dear lord where
oh in this bag please
tell me that you didn't drink your lunch
yet hi
i just got done drinking breakfast you
gotta give the liver a lot of time to
digest
so it's it's okay oh
cutie of course it is come here
you backstabbing boy [ __ ]
you are never never to see her again do
you hear me you stay away from that
london hog or i'll put fish hooks in
your nipples and fly you off the
chrysler building
why do you make me do this
[Music]
you